добре
Так Олександр думашинець проводить час
зі своєю донькою Соломією
часто приєднуються його дружина Христина
вони майже разом але це не так він удома
в Києві а вони за Тисячі кілометрів
коли я говорю з ними Що я з ними говорю
я начебто поруч Так як тільки я ставлю
трубку я розумію дивлюсь навколо і
розумію що не поруч
Олександр не може виїхати з країни через
воєнний стан а його родина в безпечній
Шотландії там у них новий будинок нова
школа нові друзі та нова мова їм
доводиться будувати нове життя
без нього
по телебаченню ми бачимо в інтернеті так
сім'ї там розходяться тому що складно
важко проте можливо через те що от нам
вдається ми от
навколо Соломійки об'єднуємось розуміємо
для чого це Олександр намагається
стежити за успіхими Соломії в школі за
допомогою відео який її надсилають
вчителі
[музика]
вони навіть відвідали його в жовтні
минулого року але світло їхнього
спільного буття затьмарили А так і
російських безпілотників на Київ
[музика]
і єдине що я в той момент молився щоб
вони виїхали тому що тоді Було дуже
страшно І коли ти дивишся на ситуацію що
тут відбувається що краще для дитини так
чи цим жертвуєш оскільки війна триває
їхню розлука починає здаватися менш
тимчасовою спочатку Олександр думав що
їм просто доведеться провести 12 місяців
окремо але тепер він погодився що
принаймні на наступний навчальний рік
для Соломії краще залишитися в Шотландії
коли ми поїхали на
місяць на два це так щось
як будто це така відпустка і є таке що я
повернуся тобто я там не кидаю корені
там нічого там
не узнаю нічого да дітей ще нікуди не
веду А коли у мене там півроку коли рік
я якось повинна жити я дітей веду в
садочок веду в школу вони там вже
пристосовуються і тому чим дальше довше
вони там будуть тим важче їм буде
повертатися
Елла лібанова десятиліттями досліджує
соціально-демографічні проблеми вона
хвилюється що чим довше триватиме війна
тим більше вкорінюватимуться діти та
їхні матерії у Нових домівках після
війни Повернення в зруйновану країну
може здатися невдалим варіантом а багато
біженців це саме ті люди які будуть
потрібні Україні
70%
жінок які виїхали після 24 лютого
мають вищу освіту
але прекрасно розумієте що якщо дружина
має вищу освіту то чоловік скоріше за
все також Тобто ми втратимо
дуже
значну частину людського і соціального
капіталу
щоб підтримувати зв’язок із донькою
Олександр читає казки на ніч
плаче Леся
важливо перш за все щоб не розривалося
цього зв’язку між нами щоб не було там
не створювалося якоїсь прірви адже ми
там спілкуємось зранку протягом дня
спілкуємось так і ввечері обов'язково
лягаємо спати разом діти вони бояться
того що їх кинули
папа десь і коли дитина папу бачить хоча
б Ну коли її казки то це
дуже добре але не всі папи можуть читати
казки бо вони можуть бути на фронті і
там недоказок но вони можуть просто
писати щось як ти можуть
договоритися про якесь там слово яке
воно пишуть коли все добре там чи я тебе
люблю І обов'язково пишуть є тати які
можуть якесь маленьке відео зробити і
дитині послати а дитина може щось
малювати
для папи і вони це люблять робити і вони
можуть розказувати
на диктофон можуть розказувати папі
посилати сьогодні ввечері Олександр
читає доньці дитячої Вірші українського
письменника Володимира вакуленка Він
загинув на війні але його слова
нагадують маленькі Соломії звідки вона
родом
[музика]